is there a difference between the dating
advice for men versus the dating advice
for women
uh yeah I would say yes obviously isn't
the dating advice for men typically how
to seduce a woman and get her into bed
while the dating advice for women is
usually how to get a man into a
relationship get him to commit and treat
you right no dating a device for men may
be amongst men who are going to the club
and just looking for a piece of tail
that night but for men who really want a
girlfriend that is not the advice
they're getting they're getting advice
on like the actual sincere men are
wondering like where do I take her what
should I do when do I call her is it too
soon or you know what's the point of all
of that because a woman of worth is
worth the trouble she's worth thinking
it through and she's worth spending time
yeah but there's on it I'm not talking
about this oh go ahead there's an end
goal like once the guy sleeps with the
girl once a girl lets you sleep with her
it's like more than likely that you can
you can date her if you play your cards
right like at that point you're on the
you're on the final the final lap if you
just don't ghost her if she lets you
sleep with her and she's not a hoe you
can likely date her but for guys it's
totally different like if a girl sleeps
with the guy it doesn't mean as much to
him because as a girl you're the one
that really gives consent as a guy
you're the one that has to go out and
earn it to be able to sleep with other
people it doesn't mean she wants to see
you again just if she's sleeping with
you unless you're you know you got micro
penis or some [__] yeah if you're a duck
but even still like if a girl is
sleeping with you it's it's more than
likely that you can date her Am I Wrong
it definitely increases it's different
it's different it's more it's more
likely with a girl than with a guy you
know what I'm saying but that's but
that's that
topic he's talking about dating advice
yeah but that's the thing like with
dating advice like for guys it's it's
like I mean I could be wrong but it's
partially like how to get girls to that
stage and then you can date them but I
guess oh it's while you're dating if
there's a girl that you like you better
be planning a nice date for her and you
better be treating a Ryan opening the
door for her and you better be picking
up the checks of course of course yeah
something I'll split the bill with her I
will find you and embarrass you yeah I
could
yeah I'd say generally that that would
be a yes I feel like that's the
objective for both sexes right men
typically go for sex and women typically
go for money
first like women I mean women don't go
necessarily for money but they'll go for
like a more of a relationship and
locking the guy down I mean
go for money
you've heard like seduce their mind
first like women we
we can end up with like a five right but
if he has like a personality he has all
these other things like but you see like
Average Joe's all the time with fine ass
women right
so if you're advising them to do just be
genuine like get to know the woman like
don't be so greasy like there is more to
us yeah totally like get to know our
mind right but with us I don't know like
it's not all about being greasy either
with with like the guy dating advice
that's shitty advice because if you're a
gentleman in everything else it makes it
even easier yeah I guess it really
depends on your goal okay if you're just
some average Schmo with a half a brain
and you just want to like you know
pounce on as many girls as you can
because it makes you feel like a man
then fine then yeah you're going to be
greasy and you're going to have yeah but
I'm saying even being greasy isn't the
move like still being a gentleman it
gets you more it does because that's
what girls like that's the whole game
that's the game of it all like I've
never pulled more girls than in college
when my game plan was to be a gentleman
like an actual gentleman that doesn't
care about the girls like I'm not
interested in you but like I'll grab you
a chair if you come over and I'm like oh
it's super nice but I'm not in like I'm
not interested it was ridiculous it was
it was ridiculous hmm free sauce Our
advice it's kind of changing now because
women are more independent and you know
it used to be like find a rich man like
find you know whatever but it's way
different now I do oh you have to
compromise and whenever you really like
somebody then you'll get to know what
they believe in and if you can relate to
that and compromise and you'll find a
common ground and you'll find your right
man and you can like know that he's not
a good man if he isn't gonna compromise
with you I feel like especially in this
generation we've just lost all
compromise we have so many unrealistic
standards so I think we're pretty much
[__] can I say that on camera well how
are men and women ever supposed to get
together if they have completely
different goals
Opposites attract
do you think Opposites Attract are like
mines like Minds both
isn't that a contradiction
it is but on women a contradiction of
themselves is there a difference this is
so foolish
what what's skank convention is this
difference between what women say that
they want in a relationship and what
they actually respond to
um absolutely I feel like like women
we're just like like we contradict by
Nature
so can you trust a woman's dating advice
no
no like I said it depends on who it
comes from because like we want a man
who treats us right but at the same time
we kind of want him to be aggressive so
it's hard to say men should not be so
aggressive don't come on to women so
hard I feel like women though should not
be so
I feel like women should kind of let
their guard down sometimes even though
men can be creeps but but I feel like
women should loosen up be more open have
more options what does that even mean
what does that even mean it it means if
you're going to be an angry feminist and
every guy that talks to you you're going
to shoot him down before before he even
don't be a complete dick just don't be a
jerk be nice to people and what the and
what she was saying about men is don't
be so aggressive like yeah you know what
that's fine let men be themselves if
he's going to be super aggressive when
you first meet him like he's he's
showing you his colors he's not going to
get any better that's his best somebody
in the beginning is showing you the best
version of themselves and if they are
they're grossing you out right at the
beginning to scram there's nothing worse
than when you're literally just trying
to do something nice and they're like I
have a boyfriend they're like they're
giving you like weird weird Vibes like
act like you're hitting on them and
you're just being nice like I was at
some bar in Orlando and there was a girl
and there that um I was hanging out with
at a concert when I was in Orlando a few
months earlier um like I wasn't even
talking to her or anything like that
seriously I was there with a mutual
friend and she was his friend so we were
all just like in the same group and so I
literally went up to say what's up to
her and she didn't remember me and she
was like oh I have a boyfriend I was
like [__] I'm just saying hi to your
ugly ass I'm not I'm not here to hit on
you yeah that's just that's just
somebody with Bad Manners I was pissed I
was pissed you get mad yeah I was like
I'm not like you're not you're
I'm gonna
Haram yeah no that's just a shitty
personality what are you gonna do yeah
she did your favor saved your dull
conversation I was just being nice no
meeting coaches dating coaches
um I think that there's something to it
right I think that they've taken the
time to understand like psychology and
dating and what works and what does this
guy why are there virtually no dating
coaches for women
um that's a good question I think mostly
because women are the ones being pursued
most of the time yep because women think
they're not sure there are so many
dating coaches for women trust me I'm a
woman I get stupid ads yeah I don't see
those ads I'm not really that
demographics yeah they absolutely are
how to find a man some of them are men
giving advice really yeah definitely not
as popular as the men's ones because
it's a lot easier to get a guy as a
woman but um yeah no but it's not it's
what women no it's it's easy to get a
guy but women you know according to
these ads you know want this
relationship they want this romantic
love do they teach them to be like good
good women or do they teach them to pain
in the asses I don't know I don't I
don't I don't study this [__] I don't
care I'm like um yeah yeah yeah I'm
totally you haven't bought all of them
yeah I got plenty of time and interest
in for that that's funny though because
women think we all have figured out
because women are emotional creatures
they're [__] crazy because women are
always jealous they're always sorry Lily
we're always jealous of each other for
some odd or Reason like they if they
want to give a woman uh advice it's
usually advice that they need to take
themselves is there a difference between
if they want in a relationship and what
they actually respond to yes so can you
trust a woman's dating advice yo guys do
that too though what he said where you
give advice that you need to do I have
plenty of friends that were giving me
advice were they then and went and did
the exact opposite like when you're done
talking to a girl or something like you
don't text her ass again like it's over
I'm getting rich I'm getting famous I'm
doing all this and then she'll hit me up
it's Newton's Second Law they always
come back but if you go chasing them
then that happens well that's the same
that's actually the same on on this end
like I've never had a boyfriend that
didn't like come around again at some
point they all do it's like oh God this
I thought this was over it's Newton's
Second Law it's like watch it's like a
judge it's like you watched a bad movie
and then the sequel comes on like get
lost
oh sometimes they say what they want
when it's not really what they need I
think maybe women should be more upfront
right away so they're not wasting their
time or leading the guy on if he has
other intentions nope what are your
thoughts on the phone no here's the
thing when women say what they want up
front they're they're thinking in their
head well I just don't want to play
games it is a game okay
learn the game and win but if you I
don't want to play games is the biggest
dumbest advice that other girls can give
to the other one just tell them how you
feel no don't tell it's like pushing
Queen D D7 right off the start like all
right I want to win let's let's skip all
the BS and we put my queen here check
yeah and then it's I don't I don't play
chess but I'll take your word for it and
then they just take your queen because
you you blundered wait what you got to
think ahead you gotta understand your
chest you gotta understand the the other
players in the game you know men like
the chase they want to be the one who
feels like they feel like they won if
they like a girl they want to feel like
they won her over and if you just you
know you just jump into his lap like a
goddamn Domino's Pizza he didn't get
that that Natural Instinct um fulfilled
of being able to hunt and and she knows
himself it's so unattractive so these
girls tell them what you want just be up
front yeah if you want to stay single
try to take that advice following
expression you don't ask a fish how to
catch a fish you ask a fisherman facts
stupid
that's the best analogy I've heard I
mean the fish isn't going to tell you
how to catch them
so you have to be skilled at what you
want so if you're the fisherman you know
how to like you know put the moves out
there you know like you're skilled in
what you want to get
there if there's somebody out there for
everyone
seem invisible to women while other guys
seem to get all the girls because you
need to step your game up
is it true most women only have eyes for
the top percentile of men 100 what
advice would you give to a man who feels
invisible to women
I would say he needs to look at what
he's doing
appearance maybe he's not showering
maybe he's not trying to you know look
good in his clothing like to me I'm
personally attracted to if you look your
best it doesn't really matter if you're
not like a 10 out of a 10 but if you at
least try to lick your best your group
the best version of yourself I wonder I
wonder who said that
[Laughter]
I'm wondering with Tom no I was talking
about Tate Tate I thought you were
talking about Tom Shay yeah you want to
talk about Tom real quick though I do
want to talk about Tom real quick all
right yeah go off so no well talk with
me so Navy SEAL Tom Shay you know what
it is this girl is saying about people
who guys who can't find a girl one of
the things that I've learned a lot about
in the past couple years is discipline
so you know sitting on the couch eating
potato chips I don't have girl how is
somebody going to be attracted to that
find you know get control of your head
control what you put in your fat face
control your mind and learn discipline
and so you stop talking yourself out of
things and so you know Tom Shea the Navy
SEAL who we work with I went through his
21 day challenge where I had to he gave
me some tasks to do every day and part
of the challenge was to wake up every
day commit to doing it and every time I
started to talk myself out of it I would
have an excuse run through my head some
lame ass excuse and there are four main
excuses that he teaches people that are
that ruin lives that's why we're doing
the 21 Day Challenge again together
which Sunny is not excited about because
he's going to have Tom on his ass first
because he knows him personally there's
21 day virtual challenge if you guys
actually would like to do that with us
go to the link in the description
because there's a discount code do it
come and do it because guaranteed in one
area of your life there's something
you're not doing because you talk
yourself out of it every day well if you
guys are interested you can go to the
top of the description click the link
and buy it with code Sunny fast50 for a
nice discount and we'll be doing it with
you guys we'll be in the zoom calls and
everything it'll be cool
um I would definitely say just be
yourself and be confident just because
like don't let your heart go cold
because somebody out here will
appreciate you and what you have to
offer when when a man is confident when
he's like I know what I want that's what
we're doing this where we're going this
how it's going to be he's going to
attract girls because naturally like we
want to be submissive a lot of women
like men to bring out their femininity
and in order to do that a man
approaching a woman helps them
let them be at ease and in their
femininity instead of having the woman
approach the man that's a lovely
perspective and and unusual for her age
group yeah I mean girls don't want to go
up to guys this is also this is as old
as time I remember being in third grade
wanting to talk to girls and I had to go
up to them they weren't going up to you
it's just it's natural am I wrong yeah
confident men ultimately met your
expectations
no so why are women so fixated on a
confident man well confidence is key
because you see more sure of yourself
like you have it all figured out but it
needs to stay like that you're the
leader and that's the thing it's like
they're not they're not any better in
fact most of the time The Confident men
are way worse than these like nice guys
so it really just comes down to to you
being just like sure of yourself if you
know like you have something to offer
why are women so attracted to confidence
if confident men often come with toxic
qualities that's a great question I
actually love that question honestly I
think that it's the toxic qualities that
sometimes bring confidence
so it's not that we're attracted
necessarily uh you know obviously not so
the toxic qualities but when you if
you're attracted to a guy who is a
little more low-key and quiet um and
doesn't come off as cocky and overtly
confident that guy may not have the
cajones to come up to you and talk to
you so the guy with the toxic qualities
you don't see those qualities right away
he is talking to you so it's so it's
somebody to you know so you so a woman
that's looking for a boyfriend it will
if she's even mildly attracted to the
toxic guy she will entertain him where
she really deep down just wants that
nice guy who's over there in the corner
who's got his [__] together but is a
little shy she that's the guy she really
wants to be hanging out with but he's
not talking to her and they're not going
up to them first we're not going up to
them first so but we've created this a
huge problem now with these uh Ultra
angry feminists and yeah you're right
you're raping girls if you go up and
talk to them at the bar nowadays yes
like I'm not even it's not even worth it
anymore right so let the host DM me but
you know a nice girl that really does
want a boyfriend and wants a guy to talk
to her the guys have now been told that
they're gonna you know be accused of
horrible things look at this I got a new
DM you want to see her see if she's real
this time she's not
ah take a look let's see it's just good
looking
she's she looks like she's 16. here she
looks like a hug no don't be saying that
you're kidding me this girl is cheap and
full of herself you're not getting
anywhere in life if this is the kind of
chicken you're gonna oh come on like yes
the Halloween pics came up yeah the
Halloween picks yes she looks great in
them but she looks like a skank now she
hit me up man have the most confident
men
so it's just like um it's like a
reflection of like
[Music]
um
of like what you give out
why do women often choose to make lists
of what they want in a relationship
rather than what they bring to the table
do they though it could go both ways but
it's always been in society about that's
absolutely true that was facts that's
something that women teach each other
make a list you ever seen all the things
that you want in a man it's so true and
nobody ever says make a list of who you
need to be to get that man it's a really
good you ever seen you ever seen a fat
chicks Tinder Tinder bio it's like three
paragraphs of what she's demanding
common thing it's like it's like all
over the Internet you don't know nothing
I don't hang out dogs on the internet
rather than what they bring to the table
table do they though it could go both
ways but it's always been a society
where the man has to be the man in the
relationship
that's how I want him to be the bigger
person
the one to bring everything to the table
well I mean don't a lot of women say
they want like a guy who's six feet tall
and six figures and six pack yeah so we
call that the rule of sixes but you
don't typically see a woman saying I
mean if they don't see a guy that's six
five six two basketball player NBA if
you don't make over 5K or 12K however
much it's to the standards the standards
are outwhelming and I blame social media
it's funny how women demand like a
dollar amount but women don't even know
how much their guy makes most of the
time they just know how much he spends
on them it's not even about how much you
make it's literally you could make 30
grand a year but if you're spending it
all on dumb [__] that the girl's gonna
like yeah or racking it up on credit
card racking up dead on credit cards you
know what I mean you can make a million
not spend it on cool [__] that she'll
like and that million doesn't matter to
her you know what I'm saying yeah this
woman said something you know about
women's expectations and he blames it on
social media and and and he and I think
he makes a really good point that social
media has you know we know that that
studies have been done that social media
makes people sad about their own lives
so they have these other hopes and
expectations that are completely
unrealistic for their station in life
and who they are and what they bring to
the table I like this [__] man five
thousand puffs
we got to get one of those
if men and women are equal why do men
always have to step up to women instead
of women stepping off their pet
their pet terms
good question
can you read that one more time that's a
good question why is dating advice
typically about coaching men to improve
but never about humbling women to accept
more average men like they did in the
past because it's all about pleasing the
woman of course why is this burden
placed on men only to become exceptional
because [__] is power
who assigns this bird in men or women I
believe women
it can be a little hard-headed and I
feel like you can kind of Coach a man a
little bit more and they'll like they
want to know like what a woman wants
why should men be expected to bring more
to the table than they ever have in
order to please women who bring less to
the table than they ever have it's funny
that she can say I'll like coach my man
but as a guy if you ever said like
you're training your girl or coaching
them in any way you're in jail you're in
Romanian person you're in Romania yes
you misogynistic piece of [__] yeah
women are the submissive ones we know
that yeah if you try to control them in
any way to think similar to you where
you have an amicable relationship and
you're a good couple then you're the big
manipulator no you're absolutely right
then you're a manipulator so do me a
favor back this up a second because he
just asked a question I wanted to
discuss why should men be expected to
bring more to the table than they ever
ever have in order to please women who
bring less to the table than they ever
have so this is something
so this is something that will you know
infuriate a question that would
infuriate feminists when women are
bringing less to the table than they
ever had and they'll and and to be fair
so women I don't know about younger
women but like younger Gen X women and
Millennial women a lot of them are
working full-time and still handling all
the stuff at the house you know the
cooking and the cleaning and the
shopping and the laundry so a lot of
them are bringing so many women are
doing that huh who's doing this Gen X
women and older Millennial women are
still doing that yeah but they're not
doing all this [__] at the home the
husband's doing it too because they both
work I know a lot of Gen X women who
work full-time and their husband doesn't
lift a goddamn finger in the house
unless something breaks and he fixes it
which is fine he's doing his so the
husband works the wife works to say that
women are bringing less than ever to the
table it you know is is a
mischaracterization because some women
are working full-time and for a lot of
women okay like don't don't no but don't
say that for the younger generation of
women I hate to break it to them but it
is true yeah that's what I'm talking
about I'm breaking it down break it down
for me breaking it down but the younger
women a lot of them they they come home
and they're like I don't I worked all
day I shouldn't have to cook I shouldn't
have to do this I shouldn't have to do
that he should be doing it and then they
put it all on the man to make up for the
older women who had to do both and
they're pissed about things like
housework and they think it's it's
beneath them so they'll live like pigs
and dirty houses because they think that
that cleaning the house shouldn't be
their job and I I've actually seen this
this is why it's better to make more
money so that your girl doesn't have to
work and then she can she can do that
[__] she can you know she'll do some
work she'll do her dumb [__] she'll
she'll try to run something but you just
sound like a such a Schmucker right now
I'm being real mom I'm being real you
don't need her going to work and you
don't need a 19 year old nitwit yeah
right [__] like that yeah right no if
she wants I'm telling you no to rephrase
what you said with a little bit of
Sanity in it is yeah make a lot of money
so she can choose she can choose if she
wants to work or if she wants to stay
home she can do her [__] that doesn't
that doesn't put Florida cleaning lady
so nobody has to fight over it who will
clean the house she can do her [__] that
doesn't put the food on the table but
she enjoys she can do her [__] well
maybe she enjoys putting food on the
table so she can do her little [__] that
she does don't listen oh I can't wait
for some woman who can straighten you
out okay let's go this is so you're
always this is personal experience this
is what I see that the guy does the
serious [__] and then the woman does her
[__] you know I'm do I'm running oh are
you now that's nice there's no
experience if you had get bent I love it
you know what you know
turn that off let's go yeah but hey
this one just tried so hard to be why
are women typically spoiled beyond their
needs because men are typically deprived
of their basically she's very good
looking
pretty pretty girl because women deserve
more
why do women often choose to make lists
of what they want in their relationship
rather than what they bring to the table
because it's women first the man is
there to accommodate for our needs
what does a woman bring to the table
so you either are these your choices
it's your choice knowledge like is your
choice either like angry feminists or
women who are like you're supposed to
just serve me I mean is that is that
like what are the other choices for you
because you're never like if that's it
you're never gonna find it no I'm
telling you man I I haven't even met a
girl and I don't even know how long that
I've like considered dating like they're
all I just can't do it maybe I'm just a
dick I just can't do it though like
they're just a few minutes ago you kind
of sounded like an [__] you know yeah
I wouldn't send my daughter to date yeah
I'm a busy man I make too many videos
with my mom what's the difference
between understanding women versus
analyzing women's
understanding women you got to care
about their feelings analyzing their
behavior just watching how they act and
react to things
I feel like analyzation comes from a
place of observation and then
understanding comes from a place of
reflection isn't one more empathetic and
the other strategic yes
so is it wrong to be strategic when it's
called The Dating Game hell yes the
dating game it gotta be it's a [__] it's
a it's a damn game man
what the [__]
don't hate the player hate the game yo
hit the player what I hate the game oh
yeah
something that would that three I didn't
not see that coming I was low-key zoned
out and it just woke me up right one
what does it mean to have game
confidence
something to bring to the table
something to offer the woman no improve
why you're the one why do you deserve
that woman men that are at the higher
percentile they know they have game so
they already know that they're a catch
game I just feel like you have great
social skills You Gotta have game you
gotta have sauce you gotta you got to be
a player now I mean you got to know how
to talk to them you know you got to let
it let it roll off the tongue the right
way now I'm saying no I don't even want
men to just be themselves why is
approaching women a skill men need to
learn why does he need game because you
got you can't make it awkward man it's
just like if you approach anybody you
want to have a comfortable uh
conversation relationship with whoever
you're talking to it's the same when
women get approached they also need to
learn how to pass the ball back so
that's what makes the game so fun is
when you're an expert at it not even an
expert but just knowing how to do it
playfully and in a good manner why do we
keep asking men to have game When
approaching women and instead ask why
are modern women so unapproachable
I think it's that modern women are
unapproachable I think it's just more so
the way men come off so it kind of makes
us have a guard up seem like we're
uncomfortable but once you get to know
again it's zero responsibility no
responsibility for how you can how you
hold yourself as a woman it's just men
it's their fault that's what she's
saying it's because the way they come at
us facts yeah no it always like that
same responsibility because of the evil
men ruining it for the good guys we get
nervous and we don't like to be
approached aggressively
um because the intentions aren't pure a
lot of the times so if you got to do it
the right way and learn game and be a
good guy modern women are just it's all
just a stupid chess game all these girls
just I feel like all these girls before
they went to this convention just stood
in front of the mirror and practiced
saying things and then going
at the end yeah that's what they all do
they're exhausted like wait wait for
realistic expectations standards so many
options that are not really even options
[Music]
we're just so focused within ourselves
we're very self-centered
many women complain that guys don't
appreciate them enough how do you know
whether to blame men for not making
enough effort for not showing enough
gratitude I think it goes hand in hand I
think some women get lost and they don't
want to show gratitude and I feel like
they don't want to be appreciative of
what their man can offer them and I
think that goes vice versa too is it
hard to satisfy people this is we just
have this this terrible epidemic of
people having crappy character everybody
again is stuck so much in their head and
they all sit and they say I have to be
true to myself and I have to follow my
heart and I'm going to express my truth
and it's such a self-centered
self-worshiping mentality that that
we've created and look at what it where
it's gotten us everybody's Furious if
they don't get what they want they can't
date each other because a really good
relationship is when everybody in the
relationship is putting the other
person's needs first if you spend if you
spent time worrying that making sure
that you were going to make your girl
you know feel comfortable and happy and
loved and she spent her time making sure
she was going to make you feel
comfortable and happy and loved how
beautiful would that be instead people
are keeping score from the second they
meet and it and it really it this whole
conversation just makes me sad yeah
oh god
um
I feel like it's harder to satisfy a
woman
because we always want the best
I blame him for that because sometimes
we do get stuck in our ways and
sometimes men
we try to think logically all the time
sometimes that's not needed so I blame
us for that one is it hard to satisfy
men or women
so why should men even bother trying to
please women if they're never satisfied
exactly that's why I'm single no I'm
joking I'm joking
but but that's the point that's exactly
exactly exactly obviously not watching
dating for women is like shopping while
dating for men is like a job interview
that he's paying for
correct it's really right
Frenchie like the dog baby like the baby
I'm twisted up
nah man enough of this [__] don't want
to see that all right thank you guys so
much for watching make sure to like
subscribe follow me on Instagram at
sunnyfast I'm giving 100 to one of you
that does so just go follow me you might
win money why not and I'll see you later
[Music]